ton sang ne circule plus dans
ton
corps tes cellules cérébrales
meurent lentement ton corps est déjà en
décomposition tu es mort D Je ne suis pas mort
oh mon Dieu réveille-toi
Anna Anab allez
non
[Musique]
laisse-moi partir s'il te plaît tu es toujours  dans
le déni s'ils te voient juste comme un
cadavre sur la dalle seulement je peux te voir c'est que
tu l'es vraiment mais je ne suis pas
mort,
je suis le seul à pouvoir t'entendre
maintenant alors prouve-moi que je suis vraiment
mort  elle n'est pas morte, est-ce qu'elle m'a
laissé
aider
Anah
[Musique]
tu dois être belle pour tes
funérailles, c'est comme ça qu'ils vont tous se
souvenir de
toi